Paris,
11h30,
patrouille de routine.
Oh putain, regarde-moi ça.
Mets le gyro.
Allez, c'est parti.
*bruit de gyrophare*
Bonjour Monsieur, vous coupez le contact s'il vous plaît.
Vous savez pourquoi on vous arrête Monsieur.
Je roulais trop vite ?
Non non, c'est pas notre problème ça.
Vous avez un autocollant à l'arrière du véhicule Monsieur.
C'est marrant ça, non ?
Ah non, c'est pas marrant ça Monsieur.
C'est une blague des années 80, vous êtes plus en règle.
C'est un pote en fait, il m'a prêté sa voit...
Bon, ça va pour cette fois.
La prochaine fois c'est 190 euros d'amende, c'est clair ?
D'accord.
Allez, circulez.
Merci Monsieur l'agent.
Bonne journée Monsieur l'agent !
J'ai pas toujours voulu être GPH mais ...
un jour je me baladais dans la rue,
je suis passé devant un salon de coiffure et ...
... c'est quand j'ai vu le nom de la boutique
que je me suis dis là...
... faut faire quelque chose quoi.
Pas de répit pour les agents qui sont à nouveau sollicités.
Cette fois-ci,
pour une intervention à domicile.
Oh merci vous êtes là, parce que moi j'en peux plus !
Parce que le perroquet il se baisse ...
Non mais laisse je te dis ! OH !
Le perroquet il se baisse comme ça
et là il dit :
"Il a plu ou je me suis pissé dans les plumes ?!"
Eh le pe...
Eh le perroquet il dit ça !
Calmez-vous.
Oh ! "Il a plu ou je me suis pissé dans les plumes ?!"
On se calme Monsieur !
OH ! Mais je suis chez moi !
Ohé oh ! EH !
Je suis chez moi, je peux faire des blagues quand même, oh !
♪ C'eeest ♪
♪ laaaa ♪
♪ jaaava ♪
♪ Trou du cul du chat ♪
♪ La bite à papa et les couilles à Jeannot ♪
♪ coincées dans le piano ♪
♪ ça fait d'la musiqueee ♪
Oui ben on a l'habitude de ce genre d'intervention.
Là c'est madame qui a appelé mais
c'est souvent les voisins aussi qui entendent des blagues à travers les murs.
Donc là on va au DHII.
C'est un service qui surveille les réseaux sociaux en permanence
et qui essaie d'identifier des modèles d'infraction qui se répètent.
Ça va, Richard ?
*soupir*
Ben le problème sur internet c'est que, avec l'anonymat,
les gens ils se permettent tout.
Donc c'est
Là par exemple je vais vous lire un tweet :
"Ta meuf à pris du poids :
avant tu te faisais un thon, maintenant elle fait une tonne."
Voilà. Et c'est signé :
"Rémi Figuemiraisin"
Donc je pourrais le chercher dans la base de donnée lui,
mais je pense que c'est pas son vrai nom.
À peine repartis, les agents sont alertés par un groupe de jeunes.
Tiens vas-y, gare-toi, gare-toi là.
Alors évidemment, on essaie de pas trop juger sur le faciès,
mais là, par expérience, vu leur dégaine,
ça,
ça veut dire "problèmes".
Bonjour.
On peut savoir ce que vous faites ?
On discute.
Ah ...
Et vous discutez de quoi ?
De rien.
Ah bon ?
Le papier de carambar là c'est quoi ?
C'est pas à moi.
C'est pas à toi ?
Alors pourquoi tu l'as jeté quand je suis arrivé ?
C'est pas un crime de manger du caramel hein !
Eh tu te calmes !
Dans 10 minutes on revient, vous êtes plus là. C'est clair ?
Encore une journée bien remplie pour la police de l'humour.
C'est avec le sentiment du devoir accompli
qu'on s'autorise enfin à se détendre.
Et demain, il faudra recommencer
car jamais rien n'est paisible
pour qui veut maintenir la paix.